diese woche hat das institut der
deutschen wirtschaft echt mal
deprimierende zahlen veröffentlicht im
jahre 2035 sind vier millionen deutsche
pflegefälle und für die wird man wohl
heißt es 500.000 pflege brauchen
man könnte auch sagen es wurde für
deutschland eine akute reisewarnung
ausgesprochen weil dann ja aber jetzt
kommt die gute nachricht die groko
reagiert und zwar mit einer pflege
offensive
der beruf des pflegers soll endlich
attraktiver werden oder wie die krise
jungen leute sagen es muss cool werden
pflegekraft zu sein und da machen wir
druck das mag man radikalen nennen oder
nicht oder krass jahren ist wilhelm
kreis ziemlich radikal krass kurjo msc
sparen vielen dank altenpflege ist
radikal viel arbeit und wird krass
scheiße bezahlt cool
sie verdienen im schnitt 20 prozent
weniger als krankenpfleger 20 prozent
weniger
es gibt die gigantische lohnunterschiede
je nachdem in welcher region man
arbeitet als pfleger hier unsere
kanzlerin hat sich neulich mal in
paderborn so ein heim angeguckt ich
freue mich sagt johannes zu sein
eine zeit in der man sich überraschendes
ob man noch neue menschen kennenlernen
frage mich jemand fragen stellten was
sagen
[Musik]
herzlichen dank dass in die 2
auch wunderbar wunderbar
die merkel im altenheim der feuchte
traum der afd
ich finde man soll seine gruppe auch
ruhig mal loben wenn es angebracht ist
sie wollen 13.000 neue pfleger auch wenn
keiner weiß wo genau die herkommen
sollen die geste zählt ich behaupte was
da in sachen überalterung auf uns alle
zukommt ist die oma aller probleme
freundlich ja das ist nicht übertrieben
eine umfrage aus dieser woche
unterstreicht noch einmal dass pfleger
im permanenten ausnahmezustand arbeiten
die sind am limit tougher geht's kaum
die lunge rtl show sensation jetzt
funktioniert geklaut stell dich der
ultimativen herausforderung bei münchen
pflege maria der älteste der welt zahlen
bis der arzt kommt
aber der kommt nie
multitasking extreme oben füttern und
gleichzeitig punkten und die bezahlte
finalrunde nachtschicht alle bewohner
klingeln aber du willst dein rücken so
in osch ist dass du nicht mehr arbeiten
kannst und selber zum pflegefall das
linker pflege warrior sind sie zu alt
bist du zu schwach
[Applaus]
ja
wir brauchen nicht nur mehr geld sondern
ein personalschlüssel in manchen
skandinavischen ländern wird übrigens
dreimal soviel für pflege ausgegeben wie
bei uns in deutschland hat man sich 1995
leider entschlossen die pflege für
private heim anbieter zu öffnen und das
war eine tolle idee denn da kann unsere
groko noch so oft einen flächendeckenden
tarifvertrag für pfleger fordern wenn
die privaten betreiber ihr veto einlegen
dann kommt er nicht
2017 haben investoren mehr als 40.000
pflegebetten bei uns erworben
über 40.000 das rekord und warum freunde
weil genau da die kohle liegt der
heute-show anlagetipp mit ulrich von
heesen
vergesst immobilien macht euch kaputt
über rohstoffe wer schlau ist der steckt
sein geld jetzt im privaten pflegeheim
wie ich immer sage und wirft falten ich
investieren die alten
jetzt suchen und sich die letzten
pfleger einem aktien sichern
ein privates pflegeheim erwirtschaftet
schnell mal über 10 prozent gewinn
solche zahlen hast du sollst du im
drogenhandel ich empfehle zum beispiel
den dk dekubitus fonds der hat die
höchste cookie dividende alte leute
diese wunderbaren runzligen gesellen
sind der letzte nachwachsenden
rohstoffen immer in deutschland haben
und sie werden immer mehr
man nennt das auch die alten progression
bzw im todesfall spricht über land
wunder kalten version
und wenn sie jetzt fragen wie schaffen
und das so viel rendite
ganz einfach indem man die pflegekräfte
scheiße bezahlt nur 50 prozent
personalkosten bei den privaten heim
wow das nenne ich eine win-win-situation
und deswegen wenn sie schnell reich
werden wollen ich bringe sie auch jetzt
immer an der elbe
also ich bin der anlageberater vor der
heute show ja ja ja ich bin auch der
anlageberater von heute schon
sie machen einen furchtbaren fehler der
heute-show anlagetipp mit dem dritten
mann von zimmer 212
[Applaus]
[Musik]